hey it's good to be here thanks for
having me I am Edith Arva I am CEO and
co-founder of launch darkly we are a
feature management platform and we
actually have a thousand customers now
stuff moves rapidly and we have names
even if you haven't heard of launch
darkly I hope you will have heard of
Atlassian Intuit and BMW who are some of
our customers worldwide we're a new
category what we say is that software
powers the world we power all teams to
deliver and control their software one
of the things I'm most proud of as an
engineer is that I get to visit
customers all over the world and I go
and talk to their software developers
and they talk about how lunch Darkly has
made their life better like made a
material difference in their happiness
they say with love sharply that they
have less stressful releases we saved
their weekend because when something
broke they could just turn it off
instead of having a scramble and do it
ha fix and they say that they get the
right feature to the right person at the
right time this is an engineer there's
pretty much all you want to feel like
you've built something great and that
people appreciate it and love it the
other thing I get more and more proud
about as time goes by is uh every time
we hire new hires we have I call it
culture and values which is if you're a
new hire you spend an hour with me and
the reason why I do this is I think that
culture is only as strong as the most
recent person you hired there is
everything that you know all this tribal
knowledge facts fun history just why
something happened that the new hire has
absolutely no idea like all the jokes
that you think everybody just gets like
oh there's a pool on the roof they don't
get it so with all the new hires I sit
them down for an hour and I say this is
your time to talk to me I'm gonna walk
through the history of the company and
you could ask me anything just don't
tweet it you know this is your time with
me
and the thing that touched me really
deeply as I was telling them about how
happy I was about how launch circle II
was changing the lives of people of our
customers
and a new hire said you know the reason
why I joined is because the person who
interviewed me a launch directly
long-term employee said it had changed
their life for the better so employee
engagement is something I play a lot of
attention to that our employees say
consistently that lunch dirkly is a
great place to work that feels really
good okay this is me this is all the
great world now 20 years ago I was a
graduating senior and I had no idea what
I was gonna do and that's the journey
I'm gonna walk you through today is
going from somebody graduating in 1999
to now so in 1999 I was a Harvey Mudd
College graduate and engineering and I
really wanted to work at a start-up like
I wanted all the things I just described
I wanted to work at a passionate team
that was building something really cool
with people I really liked working with
so I went and interviewed a couple of
companies one was a six person company
that I thought would be pretty cool and
they said well you don't really know
anything you know you're you know that's
kind of wet behind the ears you know 20
year old but I was like can't really
disagree with that and I went
interviewed at another company which was
this high flyer at the time called cyant
which did comm consulting and they're
also feeling ya know the job you want
does not always want you and this is the
number one takeaway I hope you all have
is that just cuz you don't get the job
you don't you want out of college life
still goes on you're getting a lot of
notes so what I actually did is I went
to work for a 30-person consulting shop
in Oakland and what we did is we would
go out to like a big insurance company
and this was before there was web to
tide over this was web 1.0 and we didn't
even call it web one not oh we just
called it comm we weren't big with
numbering back then and we would consult
with them about how to get more modern
and get on the web it was my first job
out of school and I was absolutely
miserable and I had a really hard time
picking apart whether I was miserable
because they just didn't like working or
or I was miserable because it was the
kind of place where I would be sitting
on my computer
and somebody would walk in and rip a
laptop off a desk and say so-and-so quit
and then I fired them this is not a
great environment so after about five
months I - quit and that was really hard
because as Robby said I like sticking
with something so the lesson I hope you
take from this is if you're really
really really miserable at a job it's
okay to quit it doesn't make you a
failure so then I went I worked at a
flashy skyscraper downtown in San
Francisco where I did the opposite thing
before we're trying to get old companies
modern now I was a dot-com consultant
and there would be these great Stanford
MBAs who had funding and they would hire
us to go actually build the product so
there was this idea back then that like
all you really needed was the idea and
then you would hire a consulting firm to
build the actual thing this was great I
had a blast like I was taking the train
down a mountain view I was hanging out
the Softbank incubator I was like this
is kind of finding the life I want to
live you know I went out to the Pacbell
Park they called it packed Bell Park
back then and they had a box where the
owner of the company took us out and
then he drove me in his Porsche and kind
of crammed in the back seat on the front
to the BART station I'm like wow will
this fun ever stop he's like no you know
we write off the boxes entertainment
expense the fun will never stop that was
baseball season Thanksgiving that year
the dot-com crash had started so all
these startups leased at Stanford MBAs
had gotten money from a lot of Silicon
Valley names you know and the bottom
fell out of the market like all these
bright ideas were just kind of propped
up by hope and when the money spigot
turned off all the people who used to
pay us money to build their ideas did I
have that money anymore so I got laid
off I think around December and this
this was pretty hard I was like wow I've
been out of college a year and three
months and I've had two jobs and I'd
like to go to a holiday party once
so then I found my third job a friend
from the first job referred me and I
went to work for a company called
epicenter ik and this is I think it's
where my career really really begin
epicentral was a software company that
was building something called portal
software it was a new category it was
really fun it was an engineering and I
got to build these new systems I got to
see what it was like to actually run a
release beginning to end before I was a
consultant where he kind of came in and
built something and left when you're
actually building and release you learn
all sorts of stuff like how to scoop
requirements what happens when you miss
Cooper requirement what happens when you
over script a requirement what happens
when a release goes really really bad
what happens when two teams build API is
that don't talk to each other what
happens when all of a sudden you have to
cut out five features that you promised
to somebody because you just need to
ship that night I had a blast of
epicenter I really learned how to
actually build software for real
I got named as an inventor on some
patents which doesn't get you any money
but looks good when you tell somebody
sometimes and I learned a lot about
building software unfortunately or
fortunately the really other cool part
about being at epicenter ik was I told
you before there was this high flier
named science that didn't give me a job
epicentral moved into the old science
office because cyant was out of business
so every day I went to work at one
market and they hadn't done it read on
any of the d course there was this
really dot-com e carpet with all these
green dots on it so I was like huh I got
the job I wanted after all and they're
all out of business
so again life has funny turns sometimes
the funny term that happened then was a
epicentral got bought by a Texas company
called vignette vignette was this public
company based in Austin and they saw a
lot of the cool stuff we were doing
about software and they wanted me to
transfer down to Austin and help run
projects on there so I took the move and
went down to vignette and I worked down
there and I was an engineering program
manager and it kind of
to the top level I was a staff
engineering low-level and you don't
really see what was next
so then I made a lateral move but I
became a product manager this was hired
because I basically reset my career I
became a product manager engineering
managers build stuff product managers
decide what to build or at least though
it's the way I thought it worked when I
became a product manager I learned the
engineer product managers taken
requirements from a lot of people bundle
them together try to satisfy a versus
various constituencies and then decide
vignette was also really fun because I
got to talk to a lot more end users so
vignette had customers all over the
world they had big newspapers in England
they had banks in Italy they had a lot
of media properties in New York they had
a media properties in Chicago so and we
also had really marquee customers that I
was proud of like NASA so my job at
vignette was I would fly all over the
world I go to these really cool
locations and get absolutely screamed at
by unhappy customers vignette had a lot
of really bad bugs at the time and there
were bad bugs like not like a really
trivial bug like this should be green
and sexually teal but a bad bug like
we're a newspaper and you just deleted
all of our content or we're a hotel
chain and hotels actually have a lot of
content they have the pictures for the
property they have that blurbs we're a
hotel property and none of the blurbs go
live so we haven't been able to book
hotels for a couple days really unhappy
people yelling at me they choked is that
I learned how to get yelled at in
several languages but the reason why
they were yelling at us is because they
bet their selves on it like I vividly
remember going to Chicago and somebody
said you know I picked you as a vendor
you're not doing well I'm gonna get
fired because I picked a bad vendor I
was like oh this is real this isn't like
some Tory this is something people
actually believe it
so from this I really learned the
importance of if you build software you
need to take it seriously people are if
you build software people are actually
going to use it and it's not just you
sitting in your nice shiny sky prett
scraper and SF like oh maybe it
shouldn't work this way like people
really depend on it alright so at
benefit I was a product manager I was
having a good time but I kept looking
back at San Francisco so this is 2007
where they started it kind of be this
research of web 2.0 and I would see what
my old friends were doing I would read
TechCrunch it would be like well that's
that's kind of where I want to be but
I'm like well I make more money here in
Austin so I kind of wavered for about
six months about you know should I move
back to SF or stay in Austin and the
thing that finally made me decided is I
was a single person I didn't have any
responsibilities and I was like why am i
acting like I'm 50 like why am I like oh
I can't quit us too risky like what's
the real risk you know the real risk is
like regretting that I didn't do this
like I want to actually go work at a
start-up I don't want to keep working at
this big public company so I quit and it
would probably the best feeling of the
world they were really surprised but it
was really fun and I then took a break
in the summer of 2007 where I biked
cross-country from Bellingham Washington
to Washington DC I decided I've been
working for a while and I just kind of
wanted to reset and do something fun
this was really fun if you ever have a
chance to take a long period of time off
between jobs I really recommend it it's
a good way to get yourself back into a
new headspace alright so I got back to
SF in 2007 all eager to go work at the
cool job I'd been wanting for forever
you know I was like now it's my chance
I'm gonna go work at the flashy startup
I'm gonna be that person this is gonna
be awesome
and I went in and interviewed at these
flashy startups and their reaction was
well you've really only been a product
manager for about a year and a half and
said well what about all this
engineering experience they're like well
you've only been a product
for a year and a half and I said but I
could do all this enterprise engineering
stuff they're like we want somebody
who's really good at consumer product
this was really brutal to me once again
I learned that the job that you fall in
love with does not always fall back in
love with you like I a when an
interviewed at Flixter which I very much
wanted to work at literally remember
their quote they're like we want
somebody who's done consumer and you
haven't so did it go work there anyway
no work that the job that actually were
one of me and went and worked at
monster.com and I actually learned a ton
so I got my own piano if you don't know
what P&L is its profit and loss so at
the time my division was making about
ten million dollars they said you want
we want to make fifteen million dollars
make it so I learned so much from that
you know I learned all about this was
kind of a dawn of Google Ads
I learned about how do you email since I
learned really had to do consumer
marketing and it was not the flashy
company it wanted but I learned a ton so
lesson for this one is even if it's not
the job you want you could still learn
something around then I finally finally
finally got the job I had always wanted
except for I didn't know that this
existed because there was a new category
there was a company called easy bloom
and they made a plant device and this
was before there was really a Wi-Fi or
even like reliably like it is now or
iPhones it was a device which you put in
a plant and it would measure the soil
the temperature the light and you'd
stick it to your computer with the USB
port and it would tell you what to grow
as an engineer I thought this was really
really cool and also somebody that had
killed many plants I thought this is
really really cool so this company at
the time was eight people they had just
come out of manufacturing and they're
about to go ready to launch and I was
like this is the perfect job for me so I
wouldn't work there and it was the
perfect job for me because it was fun it
was also the perfect job for me because
we launched it at probably the worst
time you can launch a gardening product
so we launched this product in November
of 2008 so the students here are too
young to remember this but 2008 was
right at the beginning of a global
meltdown around mortgages so everybody
was giving up their houses cutting
discretionary spending and not buying
household goods Plus November is a
terrible time for a guardian product
nobody gardens the bright side of the
story was so the first month we'd expect
it to sell around 500 units we thought
it was bad a thousand units if it was
good we actually sold twelve units like
twelve like we had made all these plans
for leg what if there's a huge surge of
people calling and asking for help how
do we get more units from China in a
hurry if we need more units playing this
elaborate launch we'd actually sent the
support person like - and like a bunker
dancer all the support calls we
anticipated getting and so we got 12
calls I mean so we got 12 units total
the break flipside of this was that was
the product manager at the time and I
told the boss the founder of the company
like hey maybe I should try doing some
marketing it's like Oh marketing and I
was like I know how to ride Google Ads I
could read some Facebook Ads maybe I
could also whip up some other stuff and
he's like here's my credit card
and so I got us by trying different
stuff I got us so that we made a million
dollars in sales in a year and it was
all because things were going so badly
they could only go better and also
because there was a brand new company
and they let me experiment like just any
success at all they saw as a success so
a lesson from this is even if you're
working at a feeling' company you have
this great opportunity how worse could
it go okay so it was an easy bloom for
about three years and then I decided I
wanted to go work for TripIt trip it was
a mobile app and they were extremely
popular around consumers they had about
when I joined about five million users
of the consumer app and I really liked
TripIt because I liked
and they hired me because they wanted to
start up a business selling a businesses
like before they've been strictly
downloading for consumers now they said
we want to ask for sale of businesses
and they looked at my resume they said
oh this is really great you have all
this business background like you're
from enterprise this is cool so like all
this experience which I thought was
completely useless was suddenly very
useful like it's really cool that you
know how to talk to you know businesses
so I joined TripIt and launched TripIt
for business got it to around a million
of dollars in revenue and concur which
was this big giant I saw what we were
doing and acquired us for roughly this
is public knowledge roughly a hundred
million dollars so this was the second
time I went through an acquisition the
second time I thought I was working for
this cool consumer company and all of a
sudden I was working for Kerr if anybody
has ever done expense reports concurred
as expense reports not the funnest thing
in the world the thing I really liked
about concur though was it was this
eighteen year old company based in
Seattle very different than most of the
companies I worked for which you were
considered an old-timer if you've been
there three years and they really
invested on their people like if you
were considered a good manager or a good
director like I was they kind of gave
you a lot of training because they
wanted to get you to the next level and
I know that at some company is training
is seen as a punishment like I've heard
at like Netscape it was like oh you're a
bad manager we're sending you to manager
trainee you know it's like a it's like a
punishment like a timeout concur did a
really brilliant job of saying this is a
treat this is us wanting to invested you
and get each of the next thing like it's
not that you're a bad speaker it's that
we want you to be a better speaker it's
not that you're a bad manager we want
you to be a better manager so we could
promote you from manager to director so
I loved this like every class they could
take there I did I really liked that
they invested in us so the lesson and
this one is even if you're working at a
big company that you don't necessarily
like his big company ish you can still
learn a lot okay
so in the background this whole time I
didn't want to start a company like I'd
worked at these really small easy Blum
was the smallest about eight people
I worked at big companies I'd launch
business divisions and I was like well
this is great I know that I could go
from zero to million but I want to do it
for myself
like I don't want to do it for somebody
else I don't want to do it as part of a
spit out I don't want to do his permit
decision when I do it for me
the issue was I had no ideas like I was
like I'm a very boring person like all I
really know how to do is build software
like that's it like I'm not like
somebody who's like oh I also know how
did you you know crazy ideas all my
friends were doing I just like all I
really know is software itself like I
know how to ship a release I know how to
design a release I know how to bring it
to market but just software stuff that's
what I love my love software you know
what I mean and my friend John Cody mill
and I had gone to college together we
would hang out he was an engineering and
we were just sit around and talk about
software you know like it's at how
should a gel be implemented silly stuff
we've seen product managers do how to
build better releases release management
that's all we talked about so John and I
kept trying to come up with an ad a
toaster tour company around finally we
decided that we would just start working
on something in ten hours a week so if
there's ever anybody you're considering
joining a company with practice it first
you don't know what it's like until you
actually work with somebody what it's
like to work with somebody sounds
obvious so what we started doing is we
started working for ten hours a week we
both kept their full-time jobs John was
at Atlassian I was at concur and we were
working already the idea for ten hours
and we cycled through about depending on
how you count it like three to seven
ideas initially we thought about doing
an app for children it apps for children
are actually very hard so there's a lot
of regulations around what content you
should show of children we thought about
doing a product ization of his PhD
thesis which was around static analysis
and we actually worked on this for a
long time we worked on this for around a
year so I was out there talking a lot of
developers
it didn't feel right and then when we
were talking to people about ideas
suddenly became really clear to us that
we should do something around feature
flags I was talking to my developer
friends they said you know what I really
like miss is the framework that I used
to have at Facebook or the framework I
used to have an Amazon or I could see
what people at Dropbox are building I
had also we'd had an internal framework
at TripIt like we had this internal
framework where we could roll features
out to different users we could control
it we can see who was using a feature
well and I had always complain about
when I was a TripIt like why is it this
a product why do we have to keep doing
in-house even when I was back at monster
calm when would I remember we had this
catastrophic release once where I really
wanted to try two different versions of
something and then be able to do a kill
switch and there just wasn't a way to do
it just like why don't we build a
product that makes software development
better and John said that's it that's
our idea like finally we have found an
idea that takes advantage of what we're
both really good at which is software
like this stuff that we thought we were
you know was it important was actually
really important because we understood
software like John had been at last seen
at a PhD and software CS I new software
inside-out so we started launch darkly
and I remember starting it because uh
Ravi who's sitting right here actually
saw one of the very first time we
pitched it convinced John my co-founder
to leave Atlassian and I had been
applying to a bunch of accelerators and
we got turned down by YC we got turned
on by 500 startups and I never heard
back from alchemists so I was just going
okay and I remember because I was going
up to Tennessee Valley to run I love
running and I was training for a hundred
mile race and I was sitting at a phone
call and I pull over to take it don't
don't take a phone call while you're
driving if your student remember nothing
about that and it was Robby and Robby
said hey you know I've been trying to
email you I want you to come in for an
interview
to be
my part of my accelerator why haven't
you responded my email so I was like
emails alright and he's like yeah it's
this is a lot of Thursday's like can you
come on on Saturday
bullying yes and then I had to go call
John who had his big going-away party
from the last scene on Friday you know
so he's been at his company for about
eight years and he had like this blowout
party plan I'm like ah John actually we
have to go down to Palo Alto 8:00 a.m.
on Saturday
sorry so we went down we went down to
alchemists accelerate pitched Ravi he
saw our very prime mortal I'd say kind
of crummy pitch and he accepted us into
alchemists and that is the beginning of
our company so the very first investor
we got was actually sitting right here
so thank you Robbie for being the first
to believe in us he saw that we had the
spark of something and I say thank you
Robbie because nobody else saw it we
gotten turned down by every other
accelerator we didn't have any customers
so I'm still shocked to this day that he
saw something okay so it's sort of this
company we had some money from
accelerator everything is just magic
then right no now came the really hard
part of going out and getting customers
John would go build John was my
co-founder and I would go out try to get
customers it took us about a year to get
nine people using it and that was with a
lot of hard work that was with if
somebody said they were remotely
interested like John and I would go show
up at their office and say okay you're
an installing now and we're not going to
leave until it's installed sometimes
it's took a couple days so the first
year was incredibly hard we were this
new product in the new market and then
nobody had heard of and if they had
heard of it they built it in-house the
one thing that really kept us going was
that the people who did use it seemed to
like it so after the first year we had
nine customers in the second year we
started charging and this is a different
metric so I say nine customers the first
year what I really mean is users so when
I ask people to start paying two of them
said we were actually only using this
as a favor to you and John I said well
can you pay like five dollars so I could
claim that we have customers and they
said no but they had used it so this is
the hard line that you have to learn if
you're gonna start a company between
users and customers like it's sometimes
better to ask for money because then you
quickly figure out whether somebody is
using it for a favor or for real however
we did have five customers this made me
really happy
one of them was a company called auction
comm we'd put up a lot of content a
landing page and they were the first
person that I didn't know who we got to
use us like they uh they signed up for
more information I gave the director of
engineering a phone call he said he
wanted a system like he'd used at
LinkedIn that would help him with
releases that had some sort of a be
testing and segmentation I said we have
exactly that he said great
so one customer that we didn't know that
was willing to pay us five figures at
the time gave me a ton of hope like
startup circum sometimes a slow slog of
just like you just look for these little
tiny sparks of hope I'm like one person
will pay us some money another customer
was really happy about was so that would
that happened in April in September we
had about seven customers paying us and
you know it was seven because every
month I had my spreadsheet where we
would put down what customer sort of
penis and every month I'm like there
better be another name or I'm gonna be
very unhappy and what made me extremely
happy was that somebody signed up and
paid that I never met I just got this
automated email they put down their
credit card of pay for it
so that like if you're starting startup
but it's really hard just always look
for some Flickr or cadence of stuff is
happening and it's starting to move so
people ask me how did you get these
customers we just put out a ton of
content I'm not a fan of stealth I know
some stanford company just got like 50
million out of stealth
that wasn't our style we were like if
people don't know who we exist nobody's
gonna use us so I wrote a ton of blogs I
did the podcasts which we talked about I
would post up on Korra
I would go to give a talk anywhere that
would have me give a talk and this was
really hard for me in the beginning
because I was super shy I was just all
about getting the word out and it worked
like people started to say hey I read
your article this looks really
interesting and we'd like to use your
software we did a big product launch and
we put a ton of effort in this product
launch and we expected to get around 400
maybe conservatively 200 customers from
this big launch because these were the
numbers we'd heard from our friends
instead we got at one one customer but
one is better than zero you know we got
one customer so it was in vision
software and again this was somebody
that wasn't a personal friend of us and
I remember the first time we had a real
call with a vision so envision is design
software and they were calling because
they had a question about something it's
we're on this call with them and then
almost all these headstock start popping
up at her screen and it was because all
the engineering managers are like this
is really important to me and I want to
also talk to the vendor it's like we're
talking John and I am a co-founder
talking also there was a and sort of
there was like 20 people all talking to
us like hey we want help with this can
you help us really whoa people really
care this is important the the final
early customer I'll talk about was true
car this was again a really cool
customer and they came in cold I didn't
know them it was a guy who was named
very poetically Joshua go which is good
for a car company and I talked to him
and he said I want we know we've built
this in-house I actually built it I
really like the internal framework but
we want to be the best car buying
company not the best infrastructure
company and so they started using us
very early and they were the customer I
referenced for when I went back about
two years after they've been using us
they talked about how happy they were
and that it had changed her life this
feels really good so my takeaway from
all this is it's really hard to get
early customers of b2b I think you
always hear about these overnight
success stories I know like stats
snapped
Stanford company were like you put
something online and you get a hundred
thousand people the next day and then a
million the next day and then you just
go buy the Lamborghini that was on us
like b2b could be a long slow roll of
just like getting a customer Guinean
customer getting a customer getting a
customer and it could also be really
slow still cycle so who here has heard
of QVC cool
so QVC is a television channel where you
could buy stuff buy stuff hey new QVC
because actually when I was back at the
plant company we'd done an infomercial
so I'd actually gone down to their
headquarters and taped this infomercial
which completely flopped but so QVC was
interested in using us at lunch sharply
and they went out and talked to them and
they're like well this is really
interesting but we don't really
understand feature flying in your
technology at all and that was an
18-month sales cycle from beginning to
end because they had to really get on
board but once they got on board they
were happy so the nice thing about b2b
is that sometimes it takes a while but
once you get people they're usually very
very loyal
so category creation is really hard I
think that take away I hope you have
from this is find something that you
really understand and love and it's okay
if you don't know what you know and love
right away like all this stuff I thought
had been like kind of those dead
knowledge that would never be used again
like the fact that I was really good at
building software the fact that had been
an engineering manager then ain't no b2b
SAS that I knew how to do content
marketing from my time at monster
suddenly became really useful later in
life so all these skills that you think
you're like why did I waste 10 years
building software when I'm still pay the
same as if I just got out of college I
actually really helped you networking
can help you it sounds really obvious
but I got a lot of jobs just because
they would let people know that I was
looking for a job like saying to people
hey got laid off was not the
christmas-card I wanted to send in 2000
but telling people that I just got laid
off helped get me a job from somebody's
like oh you got laid off come join my
company so like ask for help and ask for
help from people who know you all so
well sometimes giving it and my final
final takeaway is it's not too late like
I think there's this mythology that you
have to be 21
you know fresh out of school to have a
great idea and that you know there's a
Smith ology of the the founder as you
can't do it if you're over 30 we were
over 30 when we started the company
we've done great and I think part of why
we did great was that we did have all
this knowledge go back to the thing I
said before we had this toolbox of
different things we could pull out of
like John my co-founder like knew how to
build software really well he he and I
both knew how to manage people like we
knew how to actually execute and run a
company which was something that I think
sometimes only comes after you've worked
for a little bit so thank you all I hope
you learned some lessons and now I'm
happy to take questions
[Applause]
says down the write up for the event oh
yeah you can build the right thing but
if nobody knows about it doesn't exist
something great but if nobody knows you
exist you don't exist I learned this the
hard way at easy bloom like I said it
was this cool working sensor that we all
thought was really neat
nobody knew we exist so we didn't sell
any I'd say the transitions I made in my
life were when an engineer you just
think you build stuff when you're a
product manager you realize it's all
about building the right thing and when
you're marketer here it's all about
figuring out how to get the word about
about the thing you've built something I
learned from various jobs is that you
need to have a toolbox a toolbox of
marquee techniques a TripIt we tried to
write a lot of content around travel and
it just utterly flopped people have been
raining about travel since Marco Polo
people love blogging about their trips
they'd love showing off travel articles
there was a ton of competition we
couldn't break through that same when we
were a gardening company every newspaper
in America had or had a garden column
when we--when and I started working at
lunch darkly about getting the world
word out about this kind of
infrastructure tech product there was
not any real content about what we were
doing out there so like articles that I
thought were pretty basic got a ton of
attention one of my most popular
articles was one I called a killer
staging server about how you should
shorten deployments and it was actually
kind of a reaction to that a patent I'd
gotten years before and how I thought it
was worthless
so I best advice about marketing is to
not have just one technique to not say
like hey we're just gonna do Facebook
Ads and only that but to have kind of a
mix of different things you could try
and see which one works like for example
Facebook Ads worked really well at the
gardening company like really well so I
figured out our target
user was our target user was usually
like a 55 year old woman who is really
into gardening a really good target at
Facebook ad was somebody looking for a
gift for their mall just like every
Mother's Day like everybody's like what
should I get for mom she likes gardening
so we we had all these ads like
gardening mom green thumb mom and we
were target at people in their 20s as a
gift
same with Google like one of our best
Ronnie womans was a we would always try
to buy a Mother's Day gardening around
Mother's Day and we were getting a lot
of good clicks from that one so in
summary mark needs not just one thing
it's just everything about getting the
word out oh yeah so the question was
around fundraising and uh it was hardest
in the early days and again I think Ravi
and Alchemist and also a threshold who's
one of those sponsors who did her a it's
hurt us in the early days when your new
category because you don't have any
market size
it's not like it's hey I'm gonna go to
the database market and there's an
established category where people could
say the database market is three
trillion if you get this share from
Oracle you'll be worth you know three
billion and the early days it was just
finding people who really believed in us
and then as time went by it got easier
for us because we had more traction you
know instead of just saying hey trust us
believe us I really think our early
investors took this huge leap of faith
like in the early days you'd say hey we
have five customers but we think we're
gonna get more when you have actual
traction you can just kind of say I know
this is gonna be a big market our
customers talk for us
former Facebook software engineer and so
on
I'm here because I was curious about but
I bet your sales process is optimized to
convince the software engineer in the
company that they need your service but
not the decision-maker that controls the
budget I guess how do you overcome the
that issue because I'm sure that once
someone tries it is them and nobody
wants to go back but how do you get
another company to come beings before we
can control the budget this is a good
idea to first thank you for coming so
let me let me paraphrase you have the
individual developer who's using you you
also have the person with money and
budget who might be a VP or director how
do you convince them both and that was
one of our big challenges is to do both
so we went about it in both directions
like John my co-founder and I gave him a
ton of credit all the time he made our
SDKs our software to software
development kits that you plug into a
developers code like bulletproof like
super easy to use you can just drop them
in and use them within five minutes and
this was a lesson we learned from TripIt
trip it was consumer company and we said
we need to have delight within five
minutes what if we take that paradigm
and we put it into software developers
the documentation also has to be super
easy like developers do not want to pick
up the phone and call somebody they want
to just get it done
so bottoms up motion had to be very
smooth then we also had to get budget
from a decision maker and Howie usually
did this was in the early day is
different than how we do it now in the
early days it was a lot of people who
had either come out of a Facebook or
LinkedIn so one of our very earliest
customers auction com I referred to it
was a director who'd left LinkedIn and
he'd been brought into a new company
basically said where's the system I used
to have like I need this like I need
this to do my job so that was a little
bit more of a top-down where he had to
convince all the developers it was good
for them the other situation we usually
had is more of the troop
our situation where they built a system
or envisioned also they both both built
some sort of internal system that worked
well enough but they started a look at
the cost of maintenance you know there's
a long term cost of hey if I've pulled
you know three to eight developers off
to work on this it's not only that we
have three to eight people working on
this there's also the opportunity cost
they're not working on something else
you know it starts to really show up
more and more over time so that so in
there that's definitely how we had to
get both on board and what I learned and
I should have mentioned this before from
in being in engineering is that you
absolutely have to have the developer on
your side like if the developer does not
want to put something into their code
they will not put it into their code
like I remember arguments I was gonna
say fights but arguments they had at
TripIt when I was a product manager
about something very simple like a
tracking code and the co-founder of EP
of engineering is like I don't I don't
trust your tracking code I'm like no
it's just a pixel what's the worst thing
it happened well like engineers have to
have to have to love it if they're going
to use it
yeah so the question is when did I know
I just hurt marijuana company
well I wanted to do in 1999 I just
didn't have the skills like I own like I
always wanted to do it it was just
always it was like I don't know what I'm
doing this is a really terrible economy
and the economy in 2002 was terrible and
then it was well I'm you know I'm have
this really comfortable career why give
it all up the thing that finally tipped
it is John my friend and I were talking
and we'd already wanted to do it for a
long time and I'm like I don't want to
be talking in another 15 years about why
we didn't do this like I would rather us
say hey let's try this for two years and
if we totally fail we'll probably not be
friends anymore which will make me sad
and you'll go back and get your old job
and then I'll go back and get a similar
job I mean like that's really the worst
that could happen is well like will burn
through our savings and we'll go back to
our old life and I'm like I would much
rather take this bet then be sitting
around and be like why didn't I do this